hey i'm lucy and i love mass effect now
recently i sat in on an hour-long
presentation with bioware
about the upcoming mass effect remaster
and afterwards talk to key members of
the dev team
you'll be pleased to hear i asked very
nitpicky questions and have compiled all
the big details i learned
into this exhaustive list if you like
mass effect as much as i do
please consider subscribing we have an
exclusive interview with mack walters
about the creation of mass effect 2's
iconic suicide mission
and he even talks about some cut
characters so if you're a big fan like i
am
you'll get a lot out of it i'm not gonna
have a lot of footage of the actual
legendary edition here
so i will mark when it is and isn't the
legendary edition
all right let's kick off with the big
stuff gameplay changes to modernize
mass effect 1. let's start with combat
there's improved aim assist where the
lock on is a little bit stickier and you
can now keep locked onto targets while
you're strafing
there's finally a dedicated melee button
and yes weapons have been balanced and
tuned
across the trilogy but definitely more
so in one a huge change in combat is
that they've removed class
based weapon restrictions and aim
penalties that means you can't
train in weapons your class isn't
specialized in but you can still use
them
without being penalized what about that
inventory system though
well it's still being worked on at the
moment but from the way they were
talking about it i wouldn't expect big
sweeping changes
there is gonna be a more unified control
scheme across all three games though you
can still issue commands to your squad
mates and bioware is improving those
controls in mass effect 1 to be more in
line with how they feel
in mass effect 2. squad ai is being
improved so if you send your squad mates
over to cover they will actually get in
cover
now they're also improving enemy ai so
hopefully that means that
now every time we come across guest
we're not going to get completely rushed
by them
the hud now looks more modern cleaner
and a bit smaller
it's not right on the edges of the
screen anymore it's a little bit further
in
i did see some test footage where they
were clearly toying with changing it to
be more in line with mass effect 2 and 3
but they've dropped that it's the same
mass effect 1 hud
just cleaner animations haven't been
outright changed but they have bug fixed
a lot of them so the example that
bioware gave was a lot of the times
characters weren't necessarily looking
exactly where they were supposed to so
they fixed that
input camera and cover systems have also
been smooth to try and eliminate some of
that wonkiness you can get in mass
effect 1
and speaking of wonkiness the mako has
had
a few touch-ups to make it easier to
control which
i'm a little bit sad about because i
love that awkward old thing but i can
see why a lot of people want it
there's a ton of other small changes
that i absolutely won't have footage for
so i'm just gonna rattle through them
quickfire style in scope aim smoothing
cover pass rebalanced xp for the level
60 cap which means that you don't have
to do it in new game plus
a more consistent auto save thank god uh
improvements to boss encounters
improved cooldown for first aid mini
games are also being unified across all
platforms
you might remember that console had a
weird simon says thing and
pc had a ring thing that's going to be
unified but i'm not sure which one
we're going to be getting just yet they
also said they're going to be decreasing
the difficulty
and frequency of those minigames so
fingers crossed they'll do the same for
mass effect 2 for the safe opening and
hacking stuff because
too much okay that was a lot of gameplay
changes for mass effect 1 so let's move
to the rest of the trilogy
in particular story is there gonna be
additional story content added
no the devs did look at what was on the
cutting room floor
but unfortunately the stuff that was cut
from the games couldn't easily be put
back in for the remaster they would need
to have been built from scratch
so nothing new in the game however if
you'd like a look at some of the stuff
that did get cut including never before
seen characters
subscribe for our interview with mack
walters i've got two words for you
techno hippie elephant in the room time
which ending will you get well upon
finishing mass effect 3 in the legendary
edition
you will be presented with the extended
cut max said the extended cut provides a
lot more context
and to him is part of the canon
there's now a universal character
creator across all three games
which means that customization options
that were added in mass effect 2
and 3 are now available to you in mass
effect 1.
they've also added some new makeup skin
tones and hair styles
including more black hairstyles there's
also finally a unified female commander
shepard across the trilogy
the fem shop design wasn't finalized
until mass effect 3
so retroactively adding her back into
mass effects 1 and 2
was one of the first things the team did
when they approached the remaster
they adjusted her slightly modifying
that very powerful jawline and adding
things like wrinkles and paws
[Music]
alright the big techie one how is this
baby gonna look
and run well it'll be playable in 4k hdr
at 60 frames per second if you're
playing on ps4 pro
xbox one x ps5 xbox series
on pc though those frame rates will be
unleashed there'll be faster load times
across all platforms
so what does that mean for our beloved
elevators which is a weird sentence to
say but elevators are so
big in mass effect uh it means that
they've actually added a button so once
the level has loaded in
you can press it and skip the elevator
rides if you want to
but that music's so good why would
in terms of visual improvements you name
it and there is a decent chance they've
probably done it
for textures they used an ai uprise
program to upscale texture resolution
four times that's across the board but
some textures
even got improved up to 16 times in mass
effects 1 and
2 pretty much every character armor
outfit and weapon
were hand touched and uprezzed we got to
see a bunch of them in the presentation
and a few that really stuck out to me
were
zaid's face like that man looked
weathered you could see every wrinkle
the eye bags was so defined
he looked like a different character it
was really cool
thane as well the scales on his uh head
just looked really really good
another thing that they fixed that
really stood out to me even though it's
so small
is they fixed eyelashes so in particular
ashley
girl that clumpy mascara has gone like
it looks so much better
so when it comes to the actual levels
themselves everything was uprised with
the ai
and then the human artists went in and
made subtle tweaks and changes
to give all the levels a little bit more
life the dig site at eden prime they
moved the sun
around so you get the light coming
through the trees it looked really
really cool
um ferrous for example had was so much
more rich
in detail in vermeyer all the water
around that looked
actually like water it looked way more
realistic so
i think they did a great job if you want
a full list of the tech stuff that they
have gone in
and tweaked and changed or maybe added
to then i've got you
they've made changes too tone mapping
anti-aliasing volumetrics and fog
depth of field and bloom bucket depth of
field which they said was to enhance the
mass effect art style
subsurface scattering on the skin
ambient occlusion
which was actually only on in very very
select scenes
in mass effect 3. it's now present
across the whole trilogy
and there's probably other stuff in that
list that i didn't note down i forgot to
mention
but they've made a lot of changes
there's a brand new launcher to start
all three games from one place
at this screen you can pick which game
to play watch the credits
switch your profile and if you're
playing on xbox even uninstall specific
games
i'm not sure why you'd want to but
that's up to you they do have the
genesis comics so
when you finish one game you get brought
back to this screen and then you select
the next one you don't just roll over
into the next game it's not one
unified experience the collection
contains over 40 pieces of downloadable
content so that's story packs
armors weapons and alternate outfits so
yes that does mean you've got the dragon
age armor in there as well as the
genesis comics
however there's one piece of dlc missing
and that is pinnacle station
from mass effect 1. now if you played
mass effect 1
on ps3 you might remember that pinnacle
station wasn't there
it was actually because the source data
was corrupted i asked mac about this
and it's the exact same reason here
unfortunately which might have
consequences for achievements and
trophies
um but they weren't talking about that
mass effect 3 multiplayer didn't make it
into the legendary edition we knew that
however
according to project director mack
walters it was apparently on the table
at the very beginning
but it would have been so difficult to
implement he actually likened the amount
of effort it would take to put
multiplayer in this collection
to be on par with what it took to uplift
the whole of mass effect 1.
so it got cut so how does galactic
readiness work now
well it got rebalanced and caveat it's
still being tweaked right now
but mack was saying that it's much
easier to get the best ending
if you play through mass effect 1 2 than
three however if you just play mass
effect 3
you can still get the best ending you
just have to really max out everything
still being tweaked pc players are gonna
get a couple of nice
little additions and you won't believe
it
controller support finally
no more mods there'll be directx 11
support
21.9 support and like i mentioned
earlier an unleashed frame rate
there's no ray tracing in the legendary
edition but there are real-time
reflections so the quick explainer on
this one is that mass effect trilogy was
made in unreal engine 3
and the effort that it would have taken
to bring it into unreal engine 4 would
have been way too much for this project
but what they can do now is they can
leverage the more powerful consoles and
pcs and then each scene basically set up
a second camera and render the sequence
twice
and that's what they can use for the
dynamic real-time reflections
very cool ps5 and xbox series stuff now
when we talked to bioware they didn't
believe that there was going to be
tempest 3d audio support for playstation
5 but they did say
improvements have been made at the asset
level on sound effects so
in particular they mentioned the weapons
and guns and all those sound effects
will have been improved
the asset level not necessarily at the
system support level
also kind of sad but there is no special
dual sense stuff
there isn't quick resume there's also no
photo mode
but they were saying what they were
doing instead was leveraging the power
of the new generation of consoles and
pcs
to make all those load times way way way
faster
i wasn't lying when i said that would be
an exhaustive list of everything
in the mass effect legendary edition if
you love mass effect as much as i do
i know i've said it like twice now but
seriously you do want to watch the
interview with mark walters
so subscribe and stick around for that
i'm on twitter at lucy james games if
you want to come talk about gareth
vacarian with me
and if you don't then i should go
[Music]
you